if you want to see her take me Falcon  there's something quite special about  her  [Music]  or she's lovely isn't she you see my new  neighbor  I should go introduce myself to her she  that's a lot of man what do you do it's  complicated  always complicated or sometimes less  complicated I am pretty sure she is a  pen pal for prisoners  I don't even know him and I just can't  get her off of my mind  I'm sorry about your granddaughter what  I know how much you miss her how do you  know that I just do everyday she walks  it seems simple enough but with her it's  purposeful as though she's walking on  air  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  police officer up here he needs to see  your friends I know I didn't know I'm  here I have no idea where she is  [Music]  something is happening here and it is be  do harm to us  there's something special about her  she's so quiet she just appears and  before you know it she's gone  you  you